I don't know what to say really three
minutes till the biggest battle of our
professional lives all comes down to
today either we heal as a team we're
gonna crumble inch by inch play by play
till we're finished we're in Hell right
now gentlemen believe me and we can stay
here get the [ __ ] kicked out of us or we
can fight our way back into the light we
can climb out of hell one inch at a time
now I can't do it for you I'm too old I
look around I see these young faces and
I think I mean I made every wrong choice
a middle-aged man can make I I pissed
away all my money believe it or not I
chased off anyone who's ever loved me
and lately I can't even stand the face I
see in America
you know when you get old in life things
get taken from I mean that's that's
that's part of life but you only learn
that when you start losing stuff you
find out life's this game of inches so
is football because in either game life
or football the margin for error is so
small I mean one half a step too late or
too early you don't quite make it one
half second too slow too fast you don't
quite catch it the inches we need are
everywhere around us they're in every
break of the game every minute every
second on this team we fight for that
inch on this team we tear ourselves and
everyone else around us to pieces for
that inch raah without fear nails do
that
because we know when we add up all those
inches that's gonna make the [ __ ]
difference between winning and losing
and died
tell you this in any fight it's the guy
who's willing to die who's gonna win
that inch and I know if I'm gonna have
any life anymore it's because I'm still
willing to fight and die for that inch
because that's what living is the six
inches in front of your face now I can't
make you do it he's got a look at the
guy next year look into his eyes now I
think you're gonna see a guy who will go
to a teach wicked hello you're gonna see
a guy who will sacrifice himself for
this team because he knows when it comes
down to it you're gonna do the same for
him that's a team gentlemen here and
either we heal now as a team or we will
die as individuals
that's football guys
that's all it is
now
what are you gonna do
you